>> THAT'S THE WHOLE THING ABOUT
WHAT PRIVILEGES, PEOPLE DON'T
LIKE TO HAVE THERE PLEASURE
INTERRUPTED.
>> IF YOU REALLY WANT YOUR
PLEASURE INTERRUPTED, TUNE INTO
DON LEMON.
ANOTHER GLORIOUS MONDAY IN THE
CITY THAT NEVER SLEEPS.
THERE ARE BUMS PASSED OUT ALL
OVER THE PLACE.
BUT THE REST OF US HAVE TO STAY
UP ALL NIGHT AND GUARD OUR STUF
FROM LOOTERS.
HUNDRED SUSPECTS NABBED FOR
RIOTING HAVE ALL HAD THEIR
CHARGES ERASED.
THE CHARGES WERE WIPED OUT LIKE
A CAT AFTER HAVING ONE TOO MANY
VODKAS IN FIRST CLASS.
>> YOU'RE IN QUEENS.
THE DISMISSAL CHARGES MUST BE
GREAT NEWS TO BUSINESS OWNERS
WHO CAN LOOK FORWARD TO MORE
GROWING BASED OF FAITH LEAGUE W
WERE LOOTERS.
IT IS A LESSON IN INCENTIVE,
LACK OF PUNISHMENT DOESN'T
REMOVE A DISINCENTIVE TO CRIME,
IT BECOMES AN INCENTIVE TO DO
MORE OF IT.
AS IF THE FLAT SCREEN YOU STILL
WASN'T ENOUGH.
ACCORDING TO AN NBC, NEW YORK
INVESTIGATION, THE BRONX,
TARBORO RAVAGED BY FIRES AND
MASS INCLUDING SOME MORE THAN 6
DROPPED AND IN MANHATTAN WHEN
LOOTERS FREELY ASSAULTED IN SOHO
, OVER 200 OF THOSE ARRESTED
HAD THEIR CASES DROPPED.
ACCORDING TO THE MEDIA, POINTIN
OUT THAT PROBLEM MAKES YOU THE
PROBLEM.
TAKE NEW YORK CITY MAYOR
CANDIDATE WHO IN THE LAST
MAYORAL DEBATE TRIED TO EXPLAIN
WHAT EVERY CITIZEN IN THIS
SHAKEN TOWN UNDERSTANDS.
>> THE FACT IS MENTALLY ILL
HOMELESS MEN ARE CHANGING THE
CHARACTER OF OUR NEIGHBORHOODS.
A WOMAN COME UP MY WIFE ELLEN I
FRIENDS WITH AND HER MOM GROUP
WAS PUNCHED IN THE FACE BY A
MENTALLY ILL MAN.
THIS IS HAPPENING NEW YORK CITY
AND WERE NOT TALKING ENOUGH
ABOUT IT.
FAMILIES ARE LEAVING IS A RESULT
.
YES MENTALLY ILL PEOPLE HAVE
RIGHTS, BUT YOU KNOW WHO ELSE
HAVE RIGHTS?
WE HAVE A RIGHT TO WALK THE
STREET AND NOT FEAR FOR OUR
SAFETY BECAUSE IT MENTALLY ILL
PERSON IS GOING TO LASH OUT AT
US.
HE MAKE SENSE, HE SMOKES HE
SPEAKS SOBERLY AND THE EXACT
QUALIFICATIONS DEMOCRATS HATE
AND A MAYOR.
MICHELLE GOLDBERG WHO ON HEARIN
GANG WROTE THIS, EVERY OTHER
CANDIDATE SPOKE OF HOMELESSNESS
AS A DISASTER FOR THE HOMELESS,
YANG DISCUSSED IT AS A
QUALITY-OF-LIFE PROBLEM FOR
EVERYONE ELSE.
BECAUSE OF THAT, SHE COULDN'T
VOTE FOR IT YANG WHO.
SO SHE STUPID OR JUST LIBERALLY
MISLEADING.
SHE GOT A TRACK RECORD FOR BOTH.
BUT HER ASSUMPTION IS IF YOU
EXPRESS CONCERN ABOUT THE
LEGITIMATE SAFETY CONCERNS OF
THE CITY YOU LIVE IN, YOU LACK
COMPASSION FOR THE HOMELESS.
IT'S AS IF NORMAL FOLKS CAN'T
HOLD TWO IDEAS IN THEIR HEADS,
THAT WE CAN'T AID THE HOMELESS
AND THE CITIZENS WHO DEAL WITH
THEM ON THE STREETS.
MAYBE IT'S JUST THE WRITER THEY
CAN'T HOLD TWO IDEAS IN THEIR
HEAD AND THE STUPIDITY PREVENTS
OTHERS FROM SPEAKING OUT KNOWIN
SHE WILL LABEL THEM FASCIST FOR
WANTING TO PROTECT THEIR LOVED
ONES.
I DIDN'T THINK WEAPON ICING
COMPASSION WAS POSSIBLE, BUT
THAT'S HOW MICHAEL BOLTON GOT M
TO BUY ALL THOSE ALBUMS.
MAY BE THE IDIOCY IS DESIGNED T
MAKE YOUR READERS FEEL SMARTER.
BY THE TIME I WAS DONE READING
HER COLUMN, I FELT LIKE I COULD
COULD'VE SOLVE THE THE CUBE WIT
MY TOES.
THE NEXT TIME YOU THINK THE
STREETS FEEL LIKE UP WORDS ON,
BLAME YOU LACK A COMPASSION FOR
THIS AS JOE BIDEN'S WHITE HOUSE
AS AMERICAN CITIZENS TO REPORT
ON FRIENDS AND FAMILY WHO HAVE
BEEN INTENTIONALLY RADICALIZED
RELIEF.
THEY DIDN'T SAY REPORT ON
SOMEONE WHO DID SOMETHING, BUT
REPORT ON SOMEONE WHO BELIEVES
SOMETHING GREAT AND YOU KNOW
WHAT THAT MEANS, A DIFFERENT
POLITICAL VIEW WILL NOW BE
VIEWED AS RADICAL BECAUSE THAT'
HOW DEMOCRATS OPERATE NOW.
AND WHAT A BETTER WAY TO UNIFY
THE COUNTRY THAN HAVING FAMILIE
SNITCHING ON EACH OTHER.
REAL CRIME IS OKAY, THOUGHT
CRIME IS SEVERELY PUNISHED GREA
WHILE ACTUAL CRIMINOLOGY IS A
PROTECTED CLASS, THEY WILL DO
DEFLECT FUNDS TO OTHER INTERNAL
THREAT THAT HAS TO PRESENT
ITSELF AS A COHESIVE THING.
WHO ARE THESE MASSIVE WELL
ORGANIZED DOMESTIC TERRORIST,
YOU MEAN THE LEADERS IN THE
GANGS?
A LOT OF
WHITE SUPREMACIST.
SO WHY THIS NEW WAR ON TERROR?
IT'S A DISTRACTION, AND AN
EXPANSION OF POWER IN THIS
EXPANSION INVOLVES TARGETING
PEOPLE WHO USE RUN COUNTER TO
THE WHITE HOUSE INTIMIDATING
OPPOSITION AND DRIVING THEM
UNDERGROUND.
ALLOWING LEFT-WING MOBS TO
ATTACK YOU ISN'T FEELING WAY TO
SHUT YOU UP.
VIOLENT CRIME IS THE SILLIEST O
CONCERNS SAY THE MEDIA, IT'S
JUST PORNOGRAPHY FOR
MIDWESTERNERS SAYS POP AND FRESH
.
>> IT'S ALMOST PORNOGRAPHIC IF
YOU'RE LIVING IN THE MIDDLE OF
THE COUNTRY AND YOU READING
ABOUT SAN FRANCISCO ALL THE TIME
.
THERE'S PROBLEMS IN CITIES,
THERE'S PROBLEMS EVERYWHERE
BREAK IF YOU READ ABOUT THEM
CONSTANTLY YOU WILL BLOW THEM
OUT OF PROPORTION.
>> WHY IS IT THE LEGACY MEDIA
ONLY CARES ABOUT BLOWING THE
CRIME OUT OF PROPORTION RATHER
THAN THE CRIME ITSELF LACKS IN
JOURNALISM, ALL SIDES DESERVE T
BE HEARD, THAT'S WHY HE COVERS
THE EXPLOSION OF CRIME FROM THE
PERSPECTIVE OF WHAT'S THE BIG
DEAL?
IF YOU ARE IN KANSAS, WHO CARES
IF A BRAT GET SHOT IN TIMES
SQUARE, THIS IS THE MENTALITY
THAT LED TO THE PHRASE PEACEFUL
PROTEST PERJURER MINNEAPOLIS WA
ON FIRE, BUT SOMEWHERE KORNFIEL
WAS JUST FINE.
BOTTOM-LINE COMEDIAN CAN'T COVE
THE NEWS IF IT MAKES FAR LEFT
POLICIES LOOK BAD.
HE IS ARGUING FOR LESS COVERAGE
OF THE WIDESPREAD EXPLOSION IN
CRIME.
ISN'T THAT WEIRD COMING FROM A
JOURNALIST, TO BE ANY LESS
CONCERNED ABOUT CRIME, YOU'D
HAVE TO HOLD A SIGN THAT SAYS
DEFUND POLICE.
HEARING ABOUT PEOPLE BEATEN
ROBBED AND MURDERED IS ALMOST
LIKE PORNOGRAPHY.
I GUESS WERE CNN ANCHORS LIVE,
THEY ARE MORE CUT OFF THE LEMON
ON NEW YEAR'S EVE, IT'S WHERE
CRIME IS FOREIGN AND WATCHED
FROM BEHIND THE LOCKED FRONT
GATE PROTECTING YOUR HIGHLY
SECURE HOME.
IF YOU CONSIDER AN ASIAN ELDERL
WOMAN BEING BEATEN IN BROAD
DAYLIGHT PORNOGRAPHIC, TWINKIES
OUR YOUR ONLY PROBLEM.
MAY BE A CSX THERAPIST AND NOT
THE ONE TOOBIN IS USING EITHER.
>> LET'S WELCOME TONIGHT'S
GUESTS.
SHE SO BRIGHT, CAT HAD TO WEAR
SUNSCREEN TONIGHT, KAYLEE Mc
GEE WHITE.
HE KNOWS MORE ABOUT DEFENSE THA
THE 85 BEARS, FORMER DEFENSIVE
PEACH OF STAFF CASH PATEL.
HE WILL ONLY PROTEST IF THEY
DECLARES SET, OUTSPOKEN EDITOR
CHIEF CHADWICK MOORE.
SHE IS LIKE A GOLDFISH, SHE
SHINY AND WON'T REMEMBER ANY OF
THIS, FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR.
ALL RIGHT, CHADWICK, WELCOME
BACK TO THE SHOW.
>> THANK YOU, SIR.
>> LIKE ME LIVE IN NEW YORK AND
GOOD LOOKING.
IS ANDREW YANG RIGHT ABOUT THE
HOMELESS SITUATION HERE?
>> HE IS RIGHT.
BUT THE DEMOCRATS HAVE
ACKNOWLEDGE THEY HAVE TO ADDRES
THE HOMELESSNESS AND THE
BANKRUPTCY AND THE CITY
BASICALLY FALLING APART, BUT
HERE'S WHAT I HATE ABOUT ANDREW
YANG AND EXLEY WHAT I FIND SO
DEPRESSING IS HE IS SORT OF
DISCONTINUATION, HE'S THIS
ANNOYING LINEAL CONTINUATION OF
WHAT BLOOMBERG STARTED IN THE
IDEA THAT NEW YORK IS A LUXURY
BRAND, THAT IT'S NOT A PLACE
WHERE PEOPLE HAVE ROOTS THAT
PEOPLE LIVE.
THAT PEOPLE HAVE FAMILIES IN A
UNIQUE CULTURE OF ITS OWN, IT'S
JUST A PLACE FOR THE WORLD TO
COME.
AND THEN THERE'S NOT A NEW
YORKER.
HE JUST PLOPPED DOWN HERE, AND
IT'S LIKE THERE IS A JOURNALIST
TO SORT OF SAID THE NEW
POLITICAL PARADIGM IS A CLASS O
PEOPLE CALLED THE SOMEWHERES AN
THE ANYWHERE'S.
THE SOMEWHERES ARE MORE OF THE
SORT OF FROM PEOPLE WHO HAVE TH
SORT OF RATES AND THE ANYWHERE'
ARE JUST FLOATING AROUND
GLOBALIST.
IN ANDREW YANG IS SO MUCH
REPRESENTS THAT TRANSFORMATION
OF NEW YORK.
TO GET THIS IS AN INTERESTING
POINT BECAUSE IT EXPLAINS A
REALLY DIABOLICAL CONSEQUENCE O
THIS IS THAT THE PEOPLE THAT
COME WHEN IT GETS BAD, CAN LEAVE
, BUT THE ELDERLY, AND THE
POOR THAT LIVE IN THE CITY AND
HAVE BEEN THERE WHETHER IT IS I
THE BRONX OR HARLEM, THEY DON'T
HAVE THAT LUXURY, SO ALL OF US
LIKE WELL OFF BEAUTIFUL PEOPLE,
I MENTION MYSELF AS ONE OF THEM
WHEN THE GOING GETS ROUGH, I CA
LEAVE TO GO TO FLORIDA.
I CAN GO TO NASHVILLE, BUT ALL
OF THESE THE ASIAN FAMILIES IN
CHINATOWN THAT ARE OUT THERE
GETTING THEIR KICKED BY CRAZY
PEOPLE, THEY ARE STUCK THERE.
>> THAT'S A GOOD POINT, I WISH
CAME UP WITH IT, TOMORROW I WIL
REPEAT IT ON THE FIVE AND ACT
LIKE IT WAS MY IDEA.
WELCOME TO THE SHOW.
>> THANK YOU.
>> THIS IS YOUR FIRST TIME HERE?
>> HAS.
>> GOOD LUCK.
>> WHERE DO YOU SEE THIS GOING,
IF THE DEMOCRATS OFFER NO
SOLUTIONS THIS CAN ONLY GET
WORSE BECAUSE THEY ARE IN CHARG
FOR IT.
>> IT'S NOT ONLY GOING TO GET
WORSE, BUT YOU WILL CONTINUE TO
SEE PEOPLE LIVE LEAVE THE CITY
IN DROVES, THE PEOPLE THEY CAN
AFFORD TO WELL BECAUSE NO ONE
WANTS TO OWN A BUSINESS IN THE
CITY WHERE SHOPLIFTING IS SO
COMMON THAT A GUY IN SAN
FRANCISCO CAN WALK INTO A
WALGREENS WITH HIS BIKE AND
START SHOVELING GOODS INTO HIS
TRASH BAG AND THEN JUST WRITE
OUT ON HIS BIKE IN FRONT OF A
SECURITY GUARD IN FRONT OF ALL
THEIR CUSTOMERS.
NO ONE WANTS TO LIVE IN A CITY
WHERE AN ELDERLY ASIAN WOMAN
WILL GET BEAT IN THE FACE AND
NOBODY AROUND HER WILL DO
ANYTHING ABOUT IT.
NOBODY WANTS TO LIVE IN A CITY
THAT IS UNLIVABLE SO GOOD PEOPLE
, YOU ARE PAYING THE TAXES
IN NEW YORK CITY, WILL END UP
LEAVING TO STATES LIKE FLORIDA
AND OTHER PLACES WHERE A LOT OF
PEOPLE DURING COVID HAVE GONE.
>> IF YOUR A DEMOCRAT YOU CAN G
WELL I DON'T REALLY OWN A
WALGREENS AND I'M NOT AN ELDERL
ASIAN LADY, SO I'M SAFE, RIGHT?
I LIVE ON THE UPPER WEST SIDE,
HAVE A SECURED BUILDING WITH A
LOT OF SECURITY, SO I'M SAFE.
BUT TO THE YOUNG LADIES POINT
ABOUT BUSINESSES, WHAT ARE THE
INSURANCE COMPANIES LIKE IN THIS
, IT SEEMS TO ME THAT THEY
ARE THE DOGS THAT'S NOT PARKING
IN ALL OF THIS.
WHY IS THAT?
DO THEY TELL THESE BUSINESSES,
JUST LET THE GOODS GO, WE'LL
COVER IT?
I DON'T KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON
HERE.
>> I HAD PREPARED FOR A LOT OF
TOPICS FOR YOUR SHOW, BUT
INSURANCE WASN'T ONE SO I'M
GOING TO WING THIS.
>> I WANT TO CONGRATULATE YOU
FOR WINNING THE PGA TOURNAMENT
GREAT I LIKE THE JACKET YOU GOT.
>> WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS ON TH
STATE OF CRIME IN AMERICA THAT
IS SO GENERIC THAT EVEN YOU CAN
ANSWER IT.
>> I USED TO BE PUBLIC DEFENDER
AND A FEDERAL PROSECUTOR.
>> BOTH SIDES OF THE KIND GOING.
>> LIKE THAT?
>> YEAH.
>> IF YOU ARREST PEOPLE FOR
BEING CRIMINALS, YOU CAN'T LET
THEM OUT ON BOND.
AND THEN, YOU CAN HAVE NO CRIME
WHEN EVERYONE YOU ARREST IS
CREATING MORE CRIME AFTER THEY
ALREADY COMMITTED CRIME AND THE
WHEN THEY, THEIR THIRD CRIME,
YOU GIVE THEM LATE SENTENCE AND
SAY HERE IS MONEY FROM AN
INSURANCE COMPANY, GO TO THE BAR
.
IT DOESN'T WORK.
>> BUT YOU KNOW WHAT, BECAUSE
DEMOCRATS, IT USED TO BE, THAT
THE DEMOCRATS AND I WILL LEAVE
THE LIBERTARIANS AND THIS JUST
FOR THE SAKE OF SIMPLICITY, THE
WERE THE UNION YANG.
DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS, THEY
WERE LIKE THE FATHER, THE LAW
AND ORDER AND THEN THE DEMOCRAT
WERE COMPASSIONATE, THE MOM AND
THEY CAME TOGETHER AND THEY
FORMED A LOVING BOND THAT RULED
THE UNITED STATES, BUT IT'S NOT
THAT WAY ANYMORE BECAUSE THE
DEMOCRATS DON'T WANT TO BE SEEN
AS ALIGNING WITH THE REPUBLICAN
OVER LAW AND ORDER, SO NOW YOU
HAVE CHAOS.
>> AND OF COURSE THE FIRST
PERSON TO EVER LEAVE
LIBERTARIANS OUT, SO ABSOLUTELY
AND IF YOU WATCH THAT, YOU DON'
HAVE TO ARGUE WITH HIM, OTHER
THAN JUST TO WALK AROUND NEW
YORK.
YOU CAN SEE WITH YOUR EYES,
PHOTOS, VIDEOS THAT HE'S
COMPLETELY WRONG.
NEW YORK IS SO EXPENSIVE, AND
I'M PAYING ALL THESE TAXES AND
GIVING THE AMOUNT OF TAXES I'M
PAYING, I WOULD LIKE TO HAVE TH
LUXURY OF WALKING AROUND AT
NIGHT AND FEELING SAFE.
THE PORNOGRAPHIC ASPECT, THE
AMOUNT OF HOMELESS PEOPLE I'VE
SEEN HAVING ON THE STREET, THE
NUMBER IS NOT ZERO, IT'S NOT TWO
, IT'S NOT EVEN THREE, LAST
WEEK SAW A VAGRANT SHALL WE SAY
BEING SERVICED IN THE BUSHES
OUTSIDE OF MY APARTMENT, AND NO
ONE WANTS TO DO ANYTHING ABOUT
IT.
>> YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT KYLE.
>> YEAH.
>> WE HAD A THING, I APOLOGIZE
FOR THAT.
>> PUT KYLE UP IN A HOTEL ROOM
BECAUSE I CAN'T TAKE IT ANYMORE.
>> THE THING IS YOU ARE TALKING
ABOUT YOU HAVE A LIMIT OF
FINANCE, PEOPLE LIKE STELTER AND
, THEY ARE WILLING TO FORK
OUT THE MONEY BECAUSE THEY ARE
PROTECTED AND IN THE LONG TERM
THIS IS GOING TO END UP WITH
PRIVATE SECURITY FOR EVERYBODY
THEY CAN AFFORD IT.
>> AND YOUR NEVER EVER GOING TO
FIND THE VAST SOLUTION WHEN
YOU'RE NOT ACCEPTING REALITY AN
THE REALITY, YOU CAN PLAINLY SE
IT BY JUST LOOKING AT NEW YORK.
>> AND THIS IS GOING TO GET
WORSE FOR EVERYBODY.
AND NO WE TALK ABOUT NEW YORK,
BUT IT WAS ONCE THE BEST CITY I